let's say that the current market
settlement price for a futures contract
that specifies the delivery of a
thousand pounds of apples on October
20th and just for the simplicity of the
math in this example let's assume that
that is one year way and the current
settlement price the current market
price on the future exchange for
delivery on that date is three hundred
dollars let's also assume that the
current market price so if you were to
buy or sell apples today not on October
20th which is a year way but today let's
assume that the current market price is
$200 let's also assume that if you were
to take out a two hundred dollar loan
that you would have to pay 10 percent
interest so if you were to borrow $200
today you would essentially have to pay
back two hundred and twenty dollars in a
year now given all of the parameters
that I've set up is there a way to make
risk-free profit is there a way to kind
of arbitrage this situation and as you
can imagine there is and what we can do
is we can borrow $200 let me list it all
out we can borrow $200 borrow $200 and
then use that $200 to buy a thousand pot
of thousand pounds of apples so then we
buy one thousand 1,000 pounds of apples
we keep them in our garage or someplace
like that and then we also we also sell
sell or I guess we could say we go we
become the seller on this futures
contract or we sell the futures short I
guess is another way to think about it
so we also become the seller the seller
on the futures contract on the futures
contract so essentially we are agreeing
to sell 1,000 pounds of apples on
October 20th a year from now for $300 so
I want to show you is if we set it up
this way we are guaranteed to make money
no matter what happens to the price of
apples and that's why we're calling it
an arbitrage because if you fast forward
one year so let's fast forward one year
so in one year we definitely have a
thousand pounds of apples and just for
the sake of simplicity let's this let's
assume that apples don't get bad that
I've somehow freeze-dried them or I
don't know these are these are apples
that never spoil so let's say a year
from now I have the thousand pounds of
apples so I give the apples to settle
the futures contract give apples to
settle to settle the contract and then
of course I have my loan I have my loan
of two hundred dollars but guess what
when I settled the the contract when I
settled the futures contract I got three
hundred dollars so I get I get three
hundred dollars and what do I owe what I
owe two hundred twenty dollars on my
loan so let me subtract that out so I
owe two hundred and twenty dollars and
so I made a guaranteed risk-free eighty
dollars of profit in one year and we're
not thinking about how much money I
might have to set up side for margin but
this is essentially just free money and
if you think about it if you think about
it if this settlement price is anything
if the settlement price is anything
above the two hundred twenty dollars
then I'm going to make a risk-free
profit so if one way to think about
futures pricing is even if you think
there's going to be a cold snap and
apples are going to disappear and
there's going to be this shortage of
apples and so you might say hey maybe
the Apple prices will go up a year ago
there's always going to be a way to
arbitrage it if the settlement price if
if the growth in price is more than the
cost of borrowing the same amount of
money the cost of borrowing two hundred
dollars so in this situation the cost of
borrowing is twenty dollars so the
settlement price really shouldn't be if
we assume that there's no arbitrage
opportunities it really shouldn't be
more than two hundred and twenty dollars